well the news just broke and this is a
PR trick for those of you don't know the
PR trick is this either late on Friday
afternoon or in the middle of a major
national news story put the bad news
about your company out because it won't
be noticed in light of everything else
that's going on in other words if
there's a hurricane and a flood it's a
real in everybody's concentrating on
that and then everybody's completely
absorbed with that it's a busy news day
that's the perfect time if you can time
bad news about your company to put it
out so that this is the PR stunt start
with but today Wells Fargo announced
that they have found another 1.4 million
unauthorized accounts now to catch you
guys up that aren't up on this story
about this time last year Wells Fargo
came out and admitted that a little over
2 million accounts had been opened using
actual people's names by bank employees
at Wells Fargo in order for the bank
employees to meet their sales goals an
investigation conducted conducted by the
authorities found that the Wells Fargo
employees improperly boosted the bank
sales figures to meet their goals by
covertly opening the accounts and
funding them by transferring money from
customers actual accounts without the
owner's knowledge or permission kinda
like freaking stealing and I didn't
leave that all at the same time complete
fraud by Wells Fargo employees and it
was so rampant through the Wells Fargo
system that 5300 employees were fired
many of those fired contended that bank
supervisors had pressured them to open
ever-increasing numbers of accounts as
part of Wells Fargo retail sales drives
and of course they've paid millions of
dollars in fines and they've had to pay
millions of dollars to the customer
millions of dollars for this and was a
big big stink last year about two
million accounts a year later they now
have finished the investigation and they
have found it was not two million but
almost double that found an additional
1.4 million accounts I don't know where
you come from where I come from a
million four hundred thousand accounts
as a loft now Wells Fargo is a big
operation they're huge
tens of millions of accounts hundreds of
millions of accounts so really it's a
small percentage of their accounts
percentage-wise but truth is this is not
like one guy at a branch went rogue this
is a systemic problem through their
whole organization that's why they fire
five thousand three hundred people can
you imagine firing five thousand people
because they stole from customers Wow
so what is my conclusion well my
conclusion is this I've been telling you
for years don't do business with the big
banks don't do business with the Wells
Fargo's don't do business with the Bank
of America's why why would you submit
yourself to this kind of crap if you're
a Wells Fargo a customer still why are
you just too lazy to change your bank
account I mean there's no possible way
you should have been in there after that
thing came out last year but if you're
there now well here they come another
million four hundred thousand accounts
discovered improperly opened improperly
it's not improperly there are thieves
working inside the bank engaging in
fraudulent activity and identity theft
unbelievable yeah I mean this is crazy
y'all it's absolutely crazy and what's
crazier is some of you still bank there
so where's those rims you back well
local credit union and local small banks
regional and small town banks community
banks these are people where they
actually know your name when you walk in
you know someone at the bank you are not
a number and I can promise you that
doesn't happen at the bank of Americas
and the Wells Fargo's and so on out
there the chase I mean why in the world
would you continue to submit yourself to
this kind of crap it's not like all
these other banks don't have I mean good
Community Bank has a fabulous online
presence why in the world you need to do
business all these huh beyond me man
yeah and me I can tell you this I'm
gonna stay completely away from them
scary scary people
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]